really thinking about iraq and the
americans intentions to attack iraq
now from los angeles norman mailer talks
with author critic carol musky dukes
about his latest work the spooky art
some thoughts on writing
this writer's block event is an hour and
a half
before we start there's a volvo in the
parking lot with its lights on i don't
know the color but
see you later
good evening and thank you for coming to
tonight's program featuring norman
mailer and carol musky dukes i am andrea
grossman the founder of writer's block a
non-profit literary series dedicated to
showcasing america's great writers and
thinkers and listening to their
discourse in a setting such as this
before we get to tonight's program i'd
like to thank the skirball cultural
center for partnering with writer's
block to make this evening possible
thanks as always to amina sanchez jordan
pimer joshua jade and lee huey for their
help thanks to my volunteers and to
perry oredsky and thanks of course to
norman mailer for agreeing to come to
writer's block as his only public
appearance in los angeles
i so appreciate carol musky dukes for
taking on the challenge of engaging
norman here tonight
if if you like carol then you get
another chance to see her at writer's
block in april john lithgow will discuss
all sorts of things with her and that
will be terrific fun upcoming programs
include bill maher with ariana
huffington queen newer also with ariana
philip taubman deputy editor of the new
york times who will address the subject
of eisenhower the cia and the space
espionage program
margaret atwood erica jong alice hoffman
april smith and others if you're not now
on the mailing list do sign the forms in
the lobby and we'll get you in the
database one of these days
now for tonight this year norman mailer
celebrates his 55th year in print with
the anniversary of his first novel the
naked and the dead which was published
in 1948. the book received international
acclaim and pronounced mailer one of the
most important and influential writers
of the 20th century winner of two
pulitzers a national book award and the
author of 32 books mailer is also
credited by scholars as being the
rebellious spirit that ignited the spark
of the sixties from his founding of the
village voice his march on the pentagon
and his subsequent book armies of the
night his non-conformist and subversive
moors always a controversial and
thrilling literary and public figure
mailer takes us on
in his fiction and non-fiction from the
audacious the prisoner of sex to the
pulitzer prize-winning journalistic
piece the executioner's song
his defiant challenges to the 20th
century status quo for the last 55 years
have helped to define our literary
culture and indeed his work has helped
to crystallize the last half century
into distinct literary and social eras
in his new book the spooky art mailer
talks to us his readers about his
thoughts on contemporary culture about
literature and about what writing is all
about to an author to a reader and to a
civilization he engages us his readers
in a conversation about the art of
writing and covers a huge array of
topics therein such as where did the
words come from in the first place and
from where do those ideas spring or the
crapshoot of writing a book that may or
may not appeal to the public bearing in
mind the public's short attention span
or the long shot crapshoot of writing a
bestseller and the price the author has
to pay for writing that best seller or
his thoughts on pornography
psychoanalysis or even masturbation
don't miss that page i bet you're all
going to run out and get the book right
now such as movies and television such
as the giants of literature what mailer
has to say about tolstoy d h lawrence
and mark twain is provocative indeed but
what he has to say about his
contemporaries such as gore vidal or
saul bello or truman capote now that's
thrilling stuff
this is a book for anyone interested in
norman mailer and for anyone who's
interested in contemporary literature at
all
carol muskie dukes is interested in
literature after all she's the founding
director of the graduate school of
creative writing and literature at usc
she's the author of three novels
including the beautiful recent work life
after death she's an essayist and social
commentator with the terrific essay
collection married to the icepick killer
a poet in hollywood in addition to
several books of poetry
carol once remarked in an interview that
to be a writer you have to know
everything
well i say to interview norman mailer
you have to know everything
and that's precisely why she's the
perfect person for the task at hand
so here's what will happen tonight carol
and norman will talk after they're
through you can ask questions no
speeches please i'm the only one allowed
to give speeches tonight dutton's is
here with copies of the new book the
spooky art and they brought carol's book
to mary to the ice bit killer i urge you
to get copies of the spooky art for
yourself as well as for anyone you know
who loves mailer's work and his ideas
about his own and others writing he will
sign as many of the new as many copies
of the new book as you buy but will not
sign collections
it is now my great pleasure to introduce
norman mailer and carol musky dukes
[Applause]
hi
um happy birthday the first thing i want
to say is happy birthday happy 80th
birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
um
my first question is a little bit of an
introductory question so you can hear me
right oh yeah yeah we had a discussion
i'll let you know when i came i know we
had a discussion about the hearing aids
and uh you said if your answers get
vague that means you can't hear
yes yes
okay that's not fit i should have said
oh
[Laughter]
that'll be my clue right
um the publication of the of your new
book the spooky art some thoughts on
writing was time to coincide with your
birthday and in that celebratory spirit
i'd like to talk about this book only
not so much
the past your past
and previous work
mainly because this is a book as andrea
was saying for writers and as a writer
i'm intrigued and moved by what you have
to say about the art itself and that's
the terrain i'd like to
explore this book has been presented and
reviewed already as kind of a guide to
craft for young writers
though it's obviously not a how-to book
but i see it a little differently it
seems to me uh
though it includes you know excerpts
from interviews and other work
um interwoven with commentary it seems
to me that it's also a memoir kind of a
manifesto a sort of treasure map
pointing to
the mystery of the art drawn from memory
in other words something emerges here
which is like your your combination of
journalism and fiction something
alchemical in fact
a young writer any writer can engage
with this map
or this maze i guess follow the lit path
to it or blow it up
um
you take on enormities with gusto
you always have
um and what was interesting to me was
that is that sometimes your vision is
like shelley the poet shelly which was a
surprise to me i don't think of you as
a poet and we'll talk more about this
later well i'm not i've never been in
love with shelley no but i know but i'll
never forget that line yeah
you know babe speak reveal your buried
wisdom that idea of instinctive
knowledge right well yeah i mean i spent
half my life wondering
is it true or is it false so either way
we move in totally different directions
if we ever knew the answer well that's
what i when in terms of the title the
spookiness the idea of magic the idea of
the instinctive i think is what
undergirds this book and uh though it's
a it's a book filled with reverence
this book well reverence is not one of
my favorite words i don't care
but uh maybe it's it's certainly not
worshipfulness but there's a sense of
homage not to other writers necessarily
there is that feeling of particular
particular writers but but also to this
idea of
the magic right you mentioned this this
this anecdote about charlie devlin i
think his name is when you're a young
writer when you're doing the deer park i
believe you rented a room in a building
where he wasn't he talks about metaphor
i just want to quote back to you what
you said about him metaphor reveals a
writer's true grasp of life to the
degree that you have no metaphor you
have not yet lived much of a life yes
and you added on hearing this you began
to work on your life and your metaphors
i've been working
and actually now you claim to have
improved with age in these areas
but it it
so you've left me carol without a
question that i can hear yes
this is my plan
how no however my mission here is done i
can leave now
no i wanted you to talk about metaphor
and maybe about the idea of the magic
and the spookiness and the instinctive
knowledge of shelley was talking but
first let me clear up one point yes i
said reverence is not my favorite word
yes however resonance is oh
you misheard me
reverence always makes me think of piety
and i think piety is the uh head-on
enemy of literature
i don't think that i meant reverence
that way no i know in a pies way i think
but i when remix isn't quite the right
there's that word though when you are
you are talking about the enormities
you're talking about
profound mysteries in this book i mean
it isn't
it has been presented as a kind of guide
or craft book or whatever or collection
a kind of paste of things it is actually
i think a very mysterious book in a book
about mystery well it's filled with uh
all sorts of
thoughts and
notions that are unfulfilled yes by the
very nature of the book because in
writing
you never know the uh you never know the
end of what you're doing um
my greatest intellectual friend for sure
jean malachy
once with a
pitch a fever in a classroom
somebody said
uh mr malachy you uh you never give us
any answers all you ever bring up our
questions and he he rose to this pitch
of excitement he said there are no
answers there are only questions and and
it's true if you're a writer that the
the the best thing to be said for an
answer is it opens the way to a new
question
and after we're with everything else
that we are we're explorers
spiritual explorers central explorers
intellectual explorers uh physical
explorers but part of human nature is to
explore i mean even
uh george w bush is an explorer in that
in that he wants to see how big a bank
will come back maybe from being
sitting out a big bang you know
all right he's an suv expert may that be
the next to last political remark i make
tonight
well actually there's a point somewhere
in the book i think where you're asked
about his sex life and you say that it
would be very interesting if if someone
came up with the secret sex life of
george w bush yes yes that would be
interesting a short volume someone said
um
staying with the sources of writing you
say that there at one point there are
two kinds of writers uh you mentioned
the one kind you include faulkner
melville uh hemingway fitzgerald james
no women i notice um
right was an air that can't essentially
be they write in a way that can't
essentially be imitated but then you say
there's another kind of writer and you
say who goes on uh trying various modes
right and you mentioned not a writer but
picasso in this regard who unlike
matisse for example who worked in one
area yes well no i could expound on that
oh sure
no what i was saying is that certain
writers who we revere
there's the word
we revere we revere them because their
style has such magic to it and also has
such insularity yeah such specificity
you know there's that
there's a great happiness in
recognizing
a style or an aesthetic artifact
that speaks always of the creator
and it's identifiable
and that is by its nature mysterious
that any individual can do something
that's special and that good that
constantly
you know one of my one of the reasons
one admires henry james
is finally because he just kept that
style going all his life he kept working
on it tinkering with it adjusting it
making it more complex uh
working within its demands
and and if he had written in three or
four or five different styles his books
would have probably been much less
impressive that's my guess but then
there's the other kind of writer like ed
doctorow was a perfect example that
steinbeck
and to assert to a good extent myself
i always felt that the
greatest single influence i ever had was
picasso
and for a particularly simple reason
which is
uh i'm not being altogether facetious
about this every time uh
he had a new wife or a new mistress his
styles changed
which is so if you think of the hideous
portraits he did of women you know where
he'd start with each new woman you'd
have beautiful portraits in the
beginning and they get uglier and uglier
but at this
at the same time he was paying the most
profound culture a man can pay a woman
which is that each woman alive is a
culture unto herself
that's a good way and that's why his
style would change if you uh if you
speak french you write in one style if
you speak english you write on another
and in in a real sense
each woman that he lived with became an
absolute culture
for him that he would he would explore
within the style of that woman
well
i can't make that large a claim to my
shifts of style because they usually
i'm afraid i have to say that they often
were motivated commercially
which is since i have
nine children
somewhere along about the fifth or six
children money became very interesting
to me
and i used to sometimes i would take on
something because
i could earn enough to keep going
so
if you're doing that then your style's
going to change obligatory
because you have no choice if you're
writing a about a football team you're
not going to use the same style as if if
you're writing about a moonshot or
whatever all right
the only point i want to make
is that
there are great
disadvantages to changing your style all
the time
uh
because you irritate people tremendously
they are you they read one book of yours
and they like it a great deal they pick
up another book of yours and has nothing
to do with that first book
and and that's offensive to them yeah
they even feel suddenly cheated that you
didn't keep the same style because that
was what they had loved about you
on the other hand
my deepest feeling is it's better to
write that way i have to think that way
because i do write that way but i also
feel that
a change in style means that you're
engaged in a new attack upon reality
and i think that's fine in what we do if
we think of ourselves as being pretty
good
what we always want to do whether we're
writing poetry or a novel or even to a
small extent journalism
we want to make an attack upon reality
every movie that's made is an attack
upon the nature of reality even the bad
ones yes
and and so
um the
what i learned from picasso who's
been
you know an artist of huge interest to
me for 30 40 years before i ever try to
write a book about him
is that
the its style is the tool you use with
which to interpret reality
and if you're dealing with a new reality
that you haven't quite encountered
before you need a new style
and uh and that so that's the second
kind of writer the writer who's serious
about style but keeps looking for a new
way to exercise style and moves away
from the basic style it's interesting to
hear you talk about the change in his
life his personal life with each new
wife or mistress or a woman or whatever
because the quote i think you used was
that styles the cutting tool
that he used to attack reality
both cutting tool and attack are
obviously extremely aggressive
um
choices of words
they're my choices so willy-nilly no but
it's just interestingly to say that they
changed with the women and then to say
also there are cutting tools it is like
you know an interesting difference in
the idea of attack unless you think of
the women as a bellicose
no i think of women as being quite equal
to men so it's fair to speak of attack
yes i've noticed that you do
speaking of that i'll jump ahead a
little bit here
because i wanted to ask you more
actually about or maybe we'll go back to
attacks on reality you say the historian
historian and the novelist are both
engaged in writing fiction yes
and uh the difference is that the
historian uses more facts
though they never will be numerous
enough to enclose the reality yes and so
this idea becomes a question of plot
almost you talked about borges and how
borges takes us through many plots
in a kind of metamorphosis in a
metamorphosis right but he what he's
trying to i think if i'm understanding
you're saying before is he's trying to
approach reality uh to teach us
something about the way we approach
reality which is
is by writing the scenario that allows
us to
to create the reality
well he he shows us the uh fallacy
in depending upon a scenario right
because uh burgess is great talent and
he can do more i mean he can do more in
four or five pages than uh
in terms of plot than anyone i've ever
encountered in literature
but what borges loves to do is to put
you into a plot that's fairly
odd special but fairly recognizable and
you're comfortable and you're interested
in the plot and then almost as if he's a
magician he turns the pocket inside out
and this first plot has become another
plot entirely and while you're getting
over that he turns it into a third plot
all in five or six pages
and and what he shows us is the um
the the
he he's a torturer because he he takes
people who depend upon plot to get their
notion of existence
and and shows over and over and over
again
that plot is a malicious fallacy
and so um you're never the same if you
read bargains which is the mark of a
great writer yeah and it's interesting
the notion of plot we were talking about
this earlier had becomes the way that we
perceive the world obviously in terms of
the journalists would be included along
with historian and so on your own um
your own entry into journalism may have
been for reasons you know having to do
with uh
making some money for the children
well your your own uh entry into
journalism seemed to me to sort of
uh
question this idea of plot you know to
to move into um take the historian's
tools in a way right
this
also is in line with your idea of the
moral vision of writing because you say
there cannot be i think you say there
can be no democracy without great
writers yes
without great without uh great novelist
i was just going to say but i will say
something i'll make an amendment to that
remark
uh one always means poets yes but what
do you mean poets are what survive you
know in fascism
for a great many practical reasons not
because poets are fascists very few of
them are it's hard i hope so well
before you get into high dungeon let me
just say
no let me just say that the reason poets
are terribly important when fascism
comes
is because practically speaking that
kind of aesthetic information can be
passed much more easily
you see if you have a bad enough fascism
yeah you don't want to be seen carrying
a book right unless it's when there is
not
in the prisons during the you know
in the prisons in in russia the poets
were the ones who actually model shaman
and brodsky in fact
yes
yes but the point i want to make also
is is you don't dare be too specific in
a fascist state
a totalitarian state because if you're
too specific and your
your stuff falls into the wrong hands
then your prison lies ahead or death
so in poetry there's enough room to be
able to argue your way out of a tight
corner
and i've never heard this argument about
poetry no but i really think it's true
after all
the uh the best artists in the soviet
union uh during the the only ones who
were acceptable were two very good poets
up to a point uh vagina shinsky and yep
and and well all right yeah was a little
bit of a bully boy
you have to shake like questionable
he had questionable connections as well
but that's a whole other they all did
they had to well they were poets who
were living there
they're living in a dangerous
environment where they had to get
certain bureaucrats on their side i got
to know those two men and they were
fascinating because they totally
different men but they each had a great
skill at working the machine and yet
keeping some part of themselves intact
which is an ability very few of us have
well you know it's interesting because
the right the poets before that the
modernists like ahmadinejad and
mendelssohn were destroyed i mean not at
matava but manelstrom went to the camps
and died for writing a poem about stalin
a setai of a
more complicated but basically was
destroyed by the system the modernists
in russia the great poetry modernists
were pretty much wiped out broski left
russia was in exile put pretty much was
put into exiles for being a social
parasite in other words a poet
um
but uh you have tashenko survive
i think by being a state writer there
there are different choices that come in
i don't think by the way poets are the
only ones who make these choices
well let me not spend this evening
arguing about
uh bravo t and uh
and you have to think though
i mean i brought it up i brought it up
well no but let me ask you one other
thing you said poets are there well let
me one other quick thing about poets
because i just want to finish this off
you said that if literary if
you could think of literary forms in
terms of human relations a novel would
be like a marriage a short story would
be like
an affair that
ends quickly
and a
poem would be a one-night stand yes
however they're wrong it hurts me
no their one-night stands have changed
people's lives more than that
i knew you were going to say that
that was a good one well you obviously
were testing your chin if you knew i was
going to say that no well
i um i had the feeling that you might
say that but um i it's hard to think of
the odyssey as a one-night stand that's
all
the odyssey or even emily dickinson wild
nights wild nights
you can't hear me no oh sorry you know
what it is what we've got to look at
each other like this we've got to look
at each other like this
turn the back of our head to half the
audience right i keep thinking of what
you said about the microphone in the
book um talking about the microphone as
a fellow you know i'm going to think
this inability of mine here
is is a uh
dubious or this what
i think i'm using it
no no um
you say i think
that the novel is at best the most moral
of art forms
um
because you're exploring the interstices
of human behavior
and further um you say this is the first
approach
to religious experience in some
ways of thinking right certainly for
artists
that conventional religion doesn't
really address the terrible complexities
of moral consciousness or moral
ambiguity
and so
um
[Music]
you go so far
he just
didn't want me to finish answering the
question
i'm sorry
why don't you talk about um
i must say the novel is the most moral
of art forms these questions are
excellent
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
more of the speakers and less of the
audience okay um you the organized
religions don't begin to offer us that
kind of thing and yet you talk about the
novel as the most moral of art forms and
about uh even about reincarnation sort
of as a connection all right look you
opened up a long riff for me yeah so we
can make some people happy yes we could
good
that was a natural in in this book i
talk about something that's irritated
and irked me uh for years and i have
terribly strong opinions on it i even
fight with my own wife all the time
about it uh because my wife is a
talented woman but she has one awful
advice
she loves reading bestsellers
and and
our marriage bed uh which like any good
marriage bed has its uh honorable and
striking and exceptional moments
is polluted by these best sellers
but i hate bestsellers and i don't hate
them because they make more money than i
do i really don't it it's almost a
blessing not to make too much money if
you're a novelist because if you make a
huge amount of money you generally mess
up profoundly for the next few years
and and uh the other point is
it's irritating because everybody gets
mad
young black athletes who make seven or
eight or ten million dollars a year when
they're 22 years old and they consider
that hideous but the fact of the matter
is those kids are the best in their
sport
they're entitled to that money they're
the best ones
whereas in my profession
the mediocrities are the ones who make
huge amounts
that's true
so
but the point is what characterizes
and here i want to make a very large
metaphor if i can bring it on
what characterizes
the best seller
is 99 times out of 100 it depends upon
plot
it's plot driven
and books that are plot driven
to my mind
are heinous
because what they are they're invariably
there are better processes
if the writer
gets interested
in his or her characters
but has a plot
and this plot is laid into the project
then at a given moment the character has
to be stretched or have the ankles cut
off
the character has to fit the bed
now
talking today with michael silverblad
i came up with an
analogy that pleased me
which is it is
for the same reason that i hate
plot in books as opposed to the opposite
which is novels that are character
driven as as we speak of it in other
words when you have a novel where your
characters come alive
then
it's marvelous in writing it you have
you can have your terrible days writing
it but the best part of it is that the
characters become real to you they've
come as close as close friends and
members of your family and detested
enemies and you really become involved
what they're doing and you can't dictate
any longer what they're going to do in
order to satisfy your story they create
the story you don't
how do they create the story because
your imagination was able to create
characters who are so alive to you that
you simply cannot dominate them
and so you get a story or you don't but
what you get is is you begin to feel
closer to what imagine my imaginative
life might be like in that imaginative
life is can be immensely exciting when
you think it's revealing of real life
so in that sense as i say
i do not care at all
which is obvious by now for plot driven
novels it also occurs to me that i do
not care at all
although i consider myself a religious
man and that i believe in god and the
devil and our nearest both of them um
i am not
at all a believer in any way in formal
religion
in other words the notion that god is
all good
and all-powerful
uh strikes me as a uh an absolute
contradiction in terms
it's illogical it also is very close
people who are who are formal in their
religion
are mired
in plot
rather than character
because
the end
is implicit
in the storyline
and and the great suspense and it's why
organized religion has been able to keep
going for all these centuries
is the great suspense is that there is a
bang
out
smack ass excuse me smack out
end to it all which is you go to heaven
or to hell
well you know and that's the most
marvelous plot story of them all
you know you follow these characters
well will scarlett o'hara end up in
heaven or in hell margaret mitchell had
enough sense to have her end in the
middle
but
that notion that that
the moment we
are preordained to follow
a certain philosophy
we lose much of our individuality and
we lose the capacity
i would argue even to think morally
with finesse and subtlety the
i've spent a certain part of my reading
life as many have reading theologians
and i've often been struck particularly
with the best christian theologians
how they suffer
how they agonize within the framework
they've created for themselves
instead of taking the simple notion that
god the creator may be doing the best
that he or she can do
against huge obstacles
in a world where god is not all powerful
but is at war with the devil and both of
them mate for all we know may be working
in the lower reaches of the cosmic
corporation
but
the the point i make is
that because the novelist is not bound
by theology
because the novelist must not like the
great theologian
have to deal with incompatibles and find
ways to bludgeon their to bludgeon their
root through
which you can see in all of them
i mean from
uh all the way from martin luther luther
to nebor
you can see this business of having to
end at a given place
so sometimes you have novels with huge
talent
who create very interesting characters
but they've bound themselves they've
launched themselves to uh the plot
and at a given moment they start to
wreck their books uh the finest example
that i can think of is is
robert penn warren's
uh book what was it
all the kingsmen thank you that
he lashed himself to to the ending
and and wreck what could have been a
great american novel yeah
so that's my uh riff uh
carol i must say this rip ended just
like many a jazz riff i've heard
you know a little sort of
i
ran out of ideas perfect little segue
out into the next question just getting
back to the idea of reincarnation to you
talk about it again in terms of
the literary as if
god like a writer or an artist is is um
bringing us back to try again do a
little bit of revision yes yes i like
that idea very much you know right but
that god
it enables me to believe in karma and
reincarnation
which is god the creator
sees what we do
has an immense sense of all the things
we did right and wrong
by god's lights
recognizes the presence of the devil
uh in everything we do
in our uncontrollable impulses if you
will
and says to himself or herself
i want to give that one another try
and and it also enables god to award
heaven and hell
you see in the way you're reborn
in other words you don't go to the bel
air
or you don't wash dishes for the rest of
your life in some eternal hellhole of a
kitchen
you see no heaven or hell
what you get is a situation where you
can develop again
and in every way in which you are bad if
there's enough freedom
for the karmic monitors allow me this
little fantasy
if there's enough freedom for the karmic
monitors
they can um
situate you very well put you in a place
where those things you did not do well
in your last life impinge upon you even
more which is hellish
and and um
but on the other hand give you it also
give you the possibility to develop
those sides of yourself that never
really had a chance
so i'll try to make this more specific
so
it won't be so uh new age as it sounds
right right right and so i have a little
fantasy
which is that after i die
there i go i meet the karmic
monitor
he's very courteous and
slightly that way
and um
and he says oh mr mailer he says we're
really so happy to see you um
we've been waiting for you i have good
news for you you've been selected for
reincarnation i say thank you i rather
thought i would be
[Laughter]
and he says let's uh what would you like
to be in your next life
so i said you know i think i'd like to
be a black athlete my next slide
i said i don't care um i don't care
where i'm born i'll take it real tough
i'll put me in the worst ghetto if you
will and i'll try to work my way up but
that's what i'd like to be
well the comic monitor shuts his book
and he says oh mr mayor i have terrible
news for you very unhappy news but the
fact of the matter is that black
athletes are totally oversubscribed
everybody wants to be a black athlete in
their next life
so let me see we have you down for
something i know let me see what it is
and he opens the book
and then he blanches because he's really
rather a nice fellow on this karmic
monitor
and he says um
we've
got you down for uh
cockroach
[Laughter]
he says but there is good news in it
you're going to be the fastest cockroach
on the block
all right well the notion really what i
what i am arguing is
that i i hate sentimental karma i loathe
it
i mean this notion that you uh
you know you die and then you meet all
your relatives and everything is
wonderful and then after a while you're
reborn and soft music and so far no no
no a karma can be brutal mean
incredible
it can also be liberating in in that
you're lit you also can get out of
unfair weights or upon you
uh
let's as a simple very simple example
think of the tangle in karma
after the holocaust and and the
gas chambers
where these monitors who used to careful
study
like good scholars
to decide where this particular soul
would be going next now they had to deal
with a thousand souls who've been gassed
in a day and couldn't do a good job
so what i mean by that is it's not as if
karma is this heavenly place where
everybody gets to just desserts karma
just like god
just like the devil for that matter
they're all doing the best they can do
just as we are much of the time
now that to me that sort of existential
notion of existence
uh is much more interesting to me than
formal notions of behavior and how we
behave if there's one reason why i
really loathe the thought of george w
bush is because he uses the word evil 15
times in five minutes
absolutely
and and that is terrible it's terrible
because evil is one of the great words
we have there's love there's evil
there's god there's the devil we can go
through
10 words perhaps
15 words 20 words that will never be
anchored philosophically
because they're too rich and too complex
and meaning and anyone who throws them
around and uses them as a push button
is not to be trusted in any way at all
yes
i think
[Music]
i think the north koreans already
decided that too um questions would you
talk about
this is kind of a strange segue from
reincarnation but what if you came back
as a woman who was a writer
um what if i came back as a woman yeah a
woman who was a writer and also just i
know a lot more
yeah
you talk in the book a little bit about
different women writers not too often
you know there's not too many women
there you mentioned tony morrison
uh saying that she has helped you
understand black women you hear is that
your ear that's doing that noise that
i'm trying to hear without a hearing aid
to point out can you hear now you know
what it is it's this thing is yes it's
vibrating how about this much easier
what's making that noise oh i'm holding
my finger on the whistler i thought it
was your ear actually if you talk from
there to me can you hear it and then you
can talk on the mic to the audience i
think that might work all right
wait a minute can you hear me now okay
maybe
can you hear me okay very well know okay
yeah it was getting verbal through that
yeah um let's just put that away all
right um
the question was if you you mentioned
tony morrison and you talk about toni
morris a little bit saying that she
helps you understand the lives of black
women you mentioned joyce carol it's
kind of a backhanded compliment you say
she can get a 600 page book out of very
little
um i wouldn't call it back-handed i'd
call it a severe cause severe
smack-ass sort of
no no i have a lot of respect to joy's
paralysis a lot
and she's a wonderful example of the
imagination at work in a novelist
but i don't want to get into those
things i don't like about her work
because it would be absolutely
incompetent so since how can you read as
much of her work has been
i've been faulted for dismissing tony
morrison in that saying oh well i've
only read a couple of her books
how dare i criticize tony morrison the
basis or a couple of books well you know
uh
that that is annoying book reviewing
when you're found fault with because you
haven't read someone completely
as presumably the reviewer has oh yes
right
uh questions i do remember you talking
about virginia woolf style
somewhere else set my teeth on edge yes
it was
yes
very much an edgy reaction an actual
reaction for being almost too um what
was it use a word like that um
harsoflage something like first of large
momentum i don't know
i thought she was immensely
self-indulgent
and that while she
she had a talent
she was much too satisfied with the
smell of her own armpit
and and uh
no she babied herself all her life
she had a husband who adored her
outrageously
uh she played at the game of novel
writing with incredible literary skill
she's one of those uh partial geniuses
that just drive you up the wall
but you talk about you talk about male
novelists and eating a wife who is
supportive and so on and uh
that virginia wolf had in a way a wife
who was supportive in leonard right yes
yes um i think she was a great genius
and i think that um she doesn't keep me
alive longer though
she doesn't keep you well my idea of a
great writer is they give you a little
more life they keep you alive a little
longer
and
i must say
she's no full motor for me
she's what no pull motors i mean
when you say keep me alive that's an
interesting idea too the idea of the
novel giving you life sustenance i think
you say in another place well it can be
by the way can you all hear me when i
speak back here
it's better yeah good you're better in
general fine now we're fine
we should just
get these on
what do i mean by saying a novel gives
you life if it if the brain has
i think the human brain and the human
spirit the human soul whatever you wish
to call it this moment
because if they're all they all
circulate through each other
that if the uh
if one's spirit
is feeling flat is it am i always
there's always a part of our spirit
that's feeling flat almost always given
modern life there's no way out from that
but if there's there are times when we
really are stale within
and then we come across a book it
doesn't have to be a great novel it just
has to be a book that's right for us at
that moment it generally helps if it's
if it's a wonderful book or a great book
or a talented book or an incisive book
or even something that just releases
your rage
which is usually the cause of the
flatness
that when you get that you have more
life because you're more alive yeah
it's as simple as that and um
i found that with virginia woolf now you
feel she's a great writer and i'm not
arguing with you because
there really is no argument about taste
ever but the point is she never gave me
more life
which could have been my narrowness
but i i just always felt she's closing
down on my life she's making these
people more delicate than anybody could
ever be and survive
and in other words she's making them all
like herself and she did lots of right i
don't know i mean i think to the
lighthouse and the characters into the
lighthouse um seem to me immensely alive
well i haven't read that i've always got
this pop-up i'm an ignorant man i want
to warn you
but i do recall that you like you told
madonna that oh sorry
you told madonna she was the greatest
living artist woman artist madonna
she was the i thought she was the the
greatest female media artist around at
the time and i still feel that yeah i
think her
you know what do you call them music
videos yeah yeah i thought they were
exceptional much better than the others
yeah and some of them were very good but
she had a sense that she was awfully
good you don't like the cones though you
don't like the cones on her breasts no i
hated that yeah
she liked them
she liked outraging people which is not
the best side of madonna yeah it's it's
uh it gave her a lot of strength and she
enjoyed it and for a long time but i i
don't think it contributed anything no
well i mean uh
well that's not we won't talk about
madonna that was in another book in any
case in this book you talk about acting
you talk about theater and film yes and
literature um
in different dominions literature is
nearer to each of them in a way you say
than it is um than they are yes you know
each other yeah but we agree on that i
know from our previous conversation yeah
theater and film are are not close at
all
the only reason we think they're close
is they seem to have the same form and
of course any number of movies have been
made which would film plays
but i feel that the essence of each is
is altogether different
and and theater for example in brief
uh we go to theater and we when we when
we love theater we love it because it
teaches us a great job about social life
it teaches us an enormous amount
about manner
and mode and how you behave in the world
and how when you start to behave
strikingly in the world things go wrong
or they improve but you learn a great
deal about how to handle yourself in the
world and the fact that you're sitting
in a room with the actors
it
underwrites all that
because the actors have the prime
example of how you behave in the world
they have to behave in such a way that
the play works right whereas movies i
think
speak to deeper parts of us but not as
directly
in other words in a movie
um i've always felt there's an
underground river that goes through
movies
and it goes through uh memory
and sex
and death
and somewhere in that line memory set
sex memory
and death in there is film
it's one of the stops on the route
and and there's something truly spooky
call this uh the spooky art if i really
write about movies i guess i have to say
the prodigiously spooky art
because there's nothing spookier than a
movie
in that it's so close to a dream to
begin with
and then on top of the ways in which
it's made
make uh
put totally different demands on the
actor
than theater
the an actor can be
extraordinarily uh
extraordinarily introverted
and yet function as a good filmman
because they just have to do a piece at
a time and the nature very often of
introverts is to be able since they have
to live in the world too they are very
choosy about that way in which they will
make a statement in the world
and they use a great many resources to
come to high focus on a moment
and then they have the ability to do it
over and over and over when it's being
shot given the tolerance of the director
whereas on stage you are much more
of a necessity you're much more of a
street person
of an athlete
you you you you can't get away with
anything on stage in a certain sense if
you're creating a character every move
of that character has to be right every
moment that you're on stage very
demanding and you have to memorize huge
amounts of material and then it's the
reason it takes 20 years to become a
great stage actor you don't have to
memorize huge amounts of material but
you have to be presented as if you truly
are speaking it that you didn't have the
lines written in advance
and they are coming to you as you speak
which which is a great ability
uh i know that princess i used to make
improvised movies years ago it was
amazing how many people
who were
people who knew how to live a little bit
had a bit of a life but never acted
could act provided they didn't have to
memorize the lines
because the situation became real as
they speak to each other and you were
filming them
uh you you could get some interesting
results get a tremendous amount of waste
as well but but it it
people everybody is a natural actor to a
degree
if two businessmen meet in a lunch for
lunch they're both acting
they're always pretending to be more
powerful
and more successful or less powerful and
less successful than they really are
because whatever the needs are of the
negotiation
they are
they're looking to divert the other we
act all the time we're always pretending
to be uh warmer or colder than we really
are yeah and and so in that sense
um
in theater
uh fear is the epitome of daily of
acting in daily life
uh film acting is much subtler and odder
and people who could be wonderful in
film because of this ability to be able
to focus on each point that they're
doing
which is not possible for the stage
actor but one thing the stage actor has
the audience the audience is different
every night and the stage actor has to
have a flexibility
to adapt
to that audience out there
so i've always been fascinated with
these prodigious differences and then of
course you have a hit play
and this hit play is made into a movie
and there's a reason why they're always
even when they're successful there's
attack they're a tiny bit flat
because they don't come out of the
nature of film which is films exploring
that relation between life and the dream
that we all live with all the time but
can't quite define
my uh my late husband was we were
talking about this earlier was was an
actor um wonderful stage actor and but
he had trouble with film and i think for
some of the reasons you're talking about
the idea of acting to that circle of
glass as you say
requires that you be
focused in a way and static in a way and
also very cold within a part of yourself
uh i think was jerk bogart who once said
what you have to be able to do is to
make love to that round circle of glass
the lens yeah
and and
you know you know you you can't make
love for the actress whereas on stage
the uh marvelous element and stage is um
when there's let's say there's a love
scene on stage is everybody in the
audience is saying
how real is that really
yeah you see where's the movies uh
it's harder to tell put it that way
right and it's shot out of sequence too
there's there is no connection between
or among things um the um
getting back to the idea of the novel
you say the novel the prognosis is not
good for the novel necessarily um
maybe for poetry but will you talk about
the young i know you talked about
jonathan franzen a little bit in the
book and um
do you see the novel going you know in
terms of its
survival he's a hope i think you would
say right yeah i think i think i think
if he gets more daring he could be a
truly major runner i guess and but i
don't think he tries hard enough right
now
he's immensely skilled at what he does
immensely skilled but i don't care at
the level of which he's being immensely
skilled
i let him try for more and maybe his
success will enable him to drive him off
because his life's going to get more
interesting
well that's that's well that's the thing
about that's why all writers dream of
success because then they'll begin to
meet people who are more interesting
than the ones i know at the given moment
it's awful it's awful it's a hideous
circular equation it keeps driving you
back on yourself which is why they're
such envy in the literary world
because
people always feel i am as talented as
that person is being uh
taken on triumph road right now and he's
gonna or she's gonna get all sorts of
advantages out of this and i deserve
those advantages right and so we're
always terribly envious of each other
it's really not agreeable that way the
relations between novels are less good
than the relations between novelist
characters
very poor but as the novel dies if you
see it at dying
then there is less yeah it'll slowly get
extinguished
to the degree we get more and more
totalitarian the novel will go the
novels and luxury total terrorism could
not afford
when you also the public we don't have
to
to the degree we get more corporate with
the bottom line
demanding all the novel's going to be
squeezed down and down i think novelis
will end up being like novelists were in
russia 30 50 years ago which is they'll
do it because they love writing novels
but they'll be like poets they'll do it
they'll do it because it's their art and
they can't live without doing it but the
notion of making a living as a serious
novelist made me
pass
maybe beyond that and people won't look
to novels for
what they they have been getting
from novels for a century or more
which changes the writer too because you
said when you began with the naked and
the dead and so on there one was a major
literary figure i mean novels could be
major literary figures they could have
some
influence on the country itself right
mm-hmm when look what you hoped you
could you thought you looked at that
sometimes you did have a little
influence and you did
you know the question of democracy and
great writers comes up again yes you
know that is necessary to the
democracies you're saying if we move
toward totalitarianism all the arts even
poetry maybe will yes but for instance
abstract painting get away with anything
uh under a totalitarian regime unless
hitler's at the top of it
right
poetry can get away with a lot because
it's hard to understand
not if you write about bush i guess yeah
i mean there's a movement afoot right
now among poets to to speak out
and they're speaking out directly but
you know i think that's true to some
degree that that poetry's so-called
obscurity would put it in a slightly
different place yes
well it'll become more of a refuge for
those who care about all right anyway
will you talk about the occult a little
bit because you have a section called
the occult
in the book yes yes and um
in terms maybe of ancient evenings and
some of the things you talked about the
question of coincidence
in ancient evenings so there's very um
the idea of what was happening in your
book and then what was happening uh
elsewhere
in in well i don't think that's the
spookiest single thing that ever
happened to me in writing
which is that um
i spent 11 years working on a book about
ancient egypt called ancient evenings
and i won't get into why i got into it
it started well i'll get into it
slightly it i was fascinated with their
belief and death they believed that when
you died that was just your first death
but that there was a second death if you
were rich enough it could be protected
enough by your family and you could buy
all the amulets you needed and had all
the proper prayers set for you it was
possible to travel through the
underworld
which was a place of burning lakes of
oil and dragons and you could be
destroyed and the basic prayer in
ancient egypt for wealthy people who had
a chance of getting through the
underworld into the elysian fields where
the notion of heaven started
is uh i assume is that the the prayer
went
it would speak to the god and say oh do
not let me die a second time in the land
of the dead
so i was so taken with that i thought
this had bear some relation i've been
thinking for a long time that when you
die
a whole new set of adventures begin
which could be dire
they're not necessarily good
but that the afterlife is not a pleasant
peaceful end to everything at all
so i started that started following that
and i got more interested in egyptian
culture
now um
i've lost the point of takeover the
occult
the occult oh yes
thank you
so at a certain moment i had a
character who's probably the main
character in the book a man named men
and headed
and minute headers had had four lives
not because it wasn't reincarnation he
had the gift
of dying at the moment he was
impregnating a woman
and so he passed
from one existence into the next
with time out only for nine months
and
he's now telling the story in his fourth
life
right
and he starts telling the story in his
fourth life he uh
he speaks of his first life which had
great adventures
and in one of these great adventures was
that he uh was that he was the first
charioteer for ramses ii who was an
incredible warrior
and i had the statement headed and that
was fine and
now ramsey's the second was
uh emblazoned on many a tomb
at the walls of many of tomb many a
temple and he had his charioteer
whose name
i discovered to my amazement was meli
which was the nickname
for men and headed
in other words he was called many of
times in the book the only difference
was one was spelled with one enemy it
was spelled with two ones but it was and
i thought well this is absolutely
incredible because during these 11 years
i kept saying myself why am i spending
11 years
writing about ancient egypt what does it
have to do with my life or anyone else's
life and i mean i didn't think that all
the time but when i would get down on
the book and down on what i was trying
to do i would wonder
so that was that was just an
extraordinary moment you know
this was long after i finished the book
i came across this detail
um
so
that convinced me that there is
something
occult in writing that very often we may
be doing what cave painters did
which is we're elaborating on artwork in
order to hold off
dire gods or dread
it's a talisman it's an amulet
against some of our deepest and
uh most indefinable fears
that certainly is true of poetry yes
it's much more immediate and truthful
about poetry with that yeah half a
poetry very often the use of rough
fraction uh it involves the placating of
forces that the pokemon just about sent
yeah i think that's right i think um
in speaking mean poets i think that the
the um the whole question of of where
poetry comes together with it's
interesting that you went away to write
executioner's song i think and then came
back to ancient evenings right
which was a very different kind of
writing and almost like as in poetry i
mean field poetry is accepting like this
you came back to ancient evenings which
you said accepted you back yes it might
not have as if the the novel hadn't
since i took a terrible chance i did
it for two years and um
i came back and you know i really think
there's a muse for every novel
and the news for ancient evenings was uh
the kindest news i've ever had
i came back after two years and the view
said you look tired
here um
this never happened
take your shield let me
take your shoes off let me wash your
feet you see
and we were i was right back in the in
the book it took almost no time at all
to go back and start
and finish i now now had another year or
two to do on ancient evenings
so that was extraordinary but um
after things like that happen to you you
begin to feel that
you're entitled to call a book the
spooky art it's just not as a matter of
fact as uh
you sometimes would like it to be the
also you talk about the unsayable that
the unsayable being which again is close
to poetry that idea that you say um
somehow or other a young writer
beginning somewhere in his psyche you
know kind of hidden place in his his or
her psyche
finds a way to trust the unsayable maybe
to go wrong trusting it well that's
something else that's for young writers
i was trying
at this point because i've been trying
to talk about now for a few minutes i'd
like to get into
the uh something that may be of use to
young writers right which is
that
one of the feelings i have is that if
you're writing
and you're full of energy and what
you're writing
then it's wise to go with it even if
what your writing makes sometimes
doesn't make a great deal of sense to
you or violates some of your tenets of
what good literature should be
or it just you don't know where it came
from
but if you're writing with energy and it
could be manic energy it could be it
could be that the end of a year or a
half year or a few months you realize
what you wrote was terrible
that could happen too just because
you're writing with energy doesn't mean
it's gonna be good
but
it what it does is it opens up something
else
if for one thing it gives you a sense
which is a very important sense that you
have to be able to distinguish between
those times when you're writing with
energy and you're running well and those
times when you're running with energy
and running badly
because mania is very close to art yeah
and
so that's one thing another is that you
might have been totally locked up
and you just had a lot of debris
in your um spirit
and you had to write yourself out of
that debris you had to break through
and so the writing you're feeling very
happy while you're writing which is
often a dangerous business
you know it is like i'm going to get
into why but but
you feel very happy while you're writing
but when you look at it later it wasn't
good at all so how could you be happy
well you were happy because you were
liberating yourself from something that
was really paralyzing you even more
and that i think is is
why i i would say if you want a few
tenants one of them is if you're writing
with energy don't argue with it write it
write it and then later you'll decide
whether it was good or not good and the
more times you do it the more likely you
are to recognize that this writing is
whether it's art or therapy is crucial
you could be writing with great energy
because you're full of therapy for
yourself there's very little art in it
but that's all right sometimes in order
to get to the art you have to
write yourself out of a you've painted
yourself into a psychic corner and you
better uh write yourself out of it but
you have to find a place in which you
become a critic of your own work too
well that's very hard that takes you
very hard writing classes are good that
way right because you end up
getting a sense of of society through a
writing class right it also accelerates
the process i mean the workshop does
accelerate
and it also it makes it harder to um
be intoxicated with
one's own powers most writers who are
afraid to read their work just don't
want the the bubble burst
they want to believe that they're
wonderful
right and of course uh writing is is two
things it's an immensely private act on
the one hand and the other hands the
social line because sooner or later it
has to hit the light of day if one's
going to be a serious professional
writer you don't have to
you can be an amateur you can live
in a call and write yeah
i mean we were talking about this
earlier about how right there are
there's a proliferation of writing
classes obviously writing workshops but
what happens to ever you know not every
person who comes out of a writing
program is going to be a writer one
hopes that this person would be a good
reader for the rest of his or her life
but there are people who also write as
you say
as amateurs you know who don't do not
have to publish who may not want to
publish who may want to record one's
life in a way which is well i don't
think there are uh there are probably 50
writers who are publishing parameters
for every writer who's even at the
beginnings of professionalism but that's
that's like
there are uh a thousand baseball players
for everyone who's got a chance even to
get into a minor league so i mean that's
natural that's that's in it
and there's writing is
to the degree that it comes out of just
a desire to release attention to oneself
it's a nice form of therapy and then the
when the critical
super ego kicks in whatever it is when
you're finally able to criticize your
own work the workshop helps and then you
yourself have to learn that you learn
how to self-edit that's the difficult
time
are we getting close to time here andrew
are we okay whenever you want to take
questions
okay i know norman wanted to read
something i thought i'd read at the end
of the evening just two pages yeah it's
yeah
i think it's page 23. i don't want to
read it now i want to i'm going to read
it
okay
we're going to take questions with or
without the microphone
ted and gary are walking around
thank you very much um could you talk
briefly about the relationship between
this spookiness and occult
and the unstable and perhaps notions of
the sublime one question and also uh
would you talk a little would you talk
briefly about your early work and
whether or not the
uh occult and sublime um related all to
that uh uh i didn't quite hear all of it
uh would you talk about how the occult
and spookiness
and the unsayable and also
relate how they're related to the
sublime
how those all are related to the sublime
right so what you're asking yeah
we don't know quite how they're related
to the sublime which is uh why they
affect us so kierkegaard made one
absolutely profound remark
um which i wish our president
had come across some time in his life
and the remark is when it comes to the
remark
i'll paraphrase it because i don't
remember the exact phrasing but what he
said is that those moments in your life
when you feel most saintly and closest
to god that's at such moments you might
actually be working for the devil yeah
and vice versa at times when you really
feel that you're damned and doomed
and that
you're nothing but a slave of the devil
at that moment god might be mightily
pleased with you
uh because in fact you were working for
god
now he did that in order to free people
of the rush to judgment
and and and
you know if there's anything in
organized religion that's dangerous for
each one of the parishioners it's the
notion that they have a special taproot
to the powerhouse
and and that they don't uh you know
they've been blessed yeah and don't
argue why they've just been blessed so
kierkegaard
put out this notion that you really
cannot know your moral nature when
you're acting
so all these matters that you mentioned
that what makes them so um
uh interesting and difficult to deal
with in writing
is that you don't know that moment what
the source is
a sublime emotion may not necessarily be
sublime
it might be diabolical
and that's what makes that's what gives
that lavender edge to the oak cult
that we're always fascinated with the
occult because finally we don't know
where we are we have informations where
we are
but we really can't be certain
and and so there's there's a dreamlike
edge to the occult and the other things
you mentioned
um could you speak to uh
the point of organized religion and the
novelist with respect to graham green
and
something uh a novel such as heart of
the matter okay he's asking if you could
speak to the question of religion in the
novel in the area we're talking about
graham green
green green in like the heart of the
matter yeah
well i think green was a fine novelist
and uh
i i always enjoyed reading his novels
but really i i don't think his uh i
don't think he had that much to say
about religion fondly
you know he just believed that there was
god sort of
more likely jesus suffering in a corner
while his characters went through all
sorts of things and
his characters suffered and hated jesus
or loved jesus but but finally i was
never moved by the religion in his books
i just had to admire the art with which
he put his works together
he's one of the few people who violate
my
fondest notion which is his characters
are a little bland a little
not quite defined but his plots are
spectacular
yeah
uh yeah
i wanted to ask you a question about
writing which is something i'm
struggling with right now i was
wondering uh basically i'm interested in
honesty and audacity i think those are
two things a writer needs i think you
need to be on painfully honest and kind
of be naked with the public and you also
have to have the audacity to try to get
your stuff published
and i was sorry if you could comment on
that
yeah
well i'll try to paraphrase she's
talking about honesty and audacity that
you have to be honest in your writing
but you also have to have the audacity
to um try to get your work published
well that doesn't take audacity that
takes an agent
not not to laugh at you the the audacity
comes if you dare to send it to an agent
and get rejected
that's that agency called audacity
incorporated i think there's what what
happened right here sorry
um some of what you're saying reminded
me of coleridge at the end of biography
uh literaria and the artist is the echo
of i am and i was wondering if
if this resonates at all what you how
you would conceptualize the primary
imagination in that case
again um
talking about coleridge like in
biographical literary how would you
characterize the primary imagination
i don't know anything about coleridge
and the primary imagination he doesn't
know anything about coleridge in the
primary imagination
um
imagination and fantasy oh you talk
about reality as the ultimate this is a
different thing but you talk about
reality as the ultimate fantasy no i
talk about facts as concentrated fantasy
okay
because i've having spent a good part of
my life trying to nail down facts in
journalism so one great thing i learned
from journalism
is there's more
i had i wrote the line before i knew
what i was saying at the end of the
of the deer park
there's a
few sentences from the end there's just
a phrase that's thrown out and nothing
was more difficult to discover than a
simple fact
and then after i wrote the dear park i
spent years in journalism off and on and
i began to realize that never had i
written a sentence that was more true
facts are not facts they're concentrated
fantasies right which present themselves
as facts and in the book you talk about
the the journalists really you know
spewing out these into the machine these
factoids or whatever they are you can't
even trust statistics
it's the art of
fudging statistics
uh yes you've written about the
space program
and you talked tonight about writers
being explorers in light of the recent
u.s space tragedy what are your thoughts
about manned
space flight
i don't think i have anything very
interesting to say about that you can't
read in the papers
i think that um
i don't even know how i feel about the
space program i don't know whether uh
it's it's good or bad
whether it should go on or shouldn't go
on
and i hate questions where i just have
to waffle all over the place
and end up having to say i don't know
the answer
okay
i have a quick practical question how do
you go from
the end of one novel to the beginning of
your next novel it's such a different
profession than say the usual where
things happen fairly quickly as richard
nixon used to say i'm glad you asked
that question
years ago
years ago i've always found it hard to
read a good novelist when i'm writing
because
i've used this image over and over and
over but there you are you're working on
your novel it's this is like you're
you're a devoted auto mechanic and
you've got all the parts of your engine
out on the floor
and just then a ferrari ride spine
so it's just too tough to read a good
novel when when you're writing a novel
but the old days i used to write my
novels and then have time in between six
months or a year or whatever before i
start another novel or another book and
so i read all my contemporaries then and
that was how i'd get ready for the next
novel i would sort of pick up on what
was going on and that was one of the
ways in which
but but finally you do have to wait no
matter how you're
approaching the next novel you have to
wait until the idea for the novel comes
to you i mean an idea for a novel is is
in that extent
bears a certain comparison to love
which you can't say i'm going to fall in
love next monday
you can if you're enough of a stud say
i'm going to get laid next monday
but you can't possibly say i'm going to
fall in love next monday so
the
the business used to work for me that if
i read enough novels that would help me
to get started on the next novel but as
the years have gone by my books take
longer and longer and tend to get longer
and longer and by the time i finished
one various necessities have me working
on the next book particularly old age my
feeling is i don't want to take off six
months i want to get into this next book
because there's certain books i want to
write before i go
so i now never
almost never have time between books i
finish one book and start another
and that means i'm not reading my
contemporaries
so whatever the source is probably the
source now for writing books is just
experience
you know i just know enough about
writing i haven't done it all my life
having had the rare good fortune
to be able to do it all my life
you know the very few novelists who have
had the luck i had that from 25 on
whether they were ready or not faith
said this is the one thing you're good
at this is one thing you're likely to be
good at and so you're going to stay with
it whether you like it or not
you know i fought to get out of it i
even thought at one point becoming an
actor or a psychoanalyst i certainly uh
spent a lot of time uh
doing other things politics other things
movie making but the point
if i haven't already lost it four times
is that um
the means you use to start a new novel
are going to vary from often from book
to book
and are going to affect uh you there's
no sure road for how you're going to
start a novel because i say like love to
a great extent the novel has to happen
which is why it's not the worst idea to
be able to do non-fiction as well
because in non-fiction if you have the
skills to write you can always do a book
on non-fiction it may not be a very very
good book it may be just a fairly good
book but you can always do non-fiction
you can't always do a novel
comes from from a deeper source in
yourself or wherever
okay well i have two short questions
first you said that in living
preordained lives we lose some of our
individuality and i was wondering if you
could extend that idea to say those of
us that live our lives according to
social convention so like marriage for
example do we lose our individuality in
accepting marriage
and my second question is just if you
have any further tips i think it follows
up that question pretty well um for
young writers and how they can get
inspired and where we can find
inspiration here's the mercy of carol
musky dukes who's going to
paraphrase what you said
i feel like a simultaneous translator
yes i don't know if i remember that
first one exactly you asked a question
about living the pre-ordained life is
that right
you lose your individuality and living a
pre-ordained life and i think you asked
to further you elaborated on it as far
as marriage like being married
if you could extend the idea into
marriage living the pre-ordained life
oh but marriage is very rarely
pre-ordained
really all sorts of things happen in
marriage and uh
marriage is analogous to a novel a novel
that's character driven
yes
or worse than you think they will
and if you're very spoiled uh
it's like you're a writer who throws
away a manuscript before
the real test has been taken
with uh whether you should write that
book or not but no marriage is an
immensely interesting uh human
relationship
at its worst it's what i call an
excrementitious relationship
no really because most people nearly all
of us are timid and cowardly in many
fashions and so what you look for
finally is to find someone that you can
dump on
provided you're willing to take their
dumping on you
the the best marriages have this species
of equality to them and you don't have
to go out in the world and fight with
everyone you meet who irritates you you
can you can take it out on your mate you
have it right at home right
now the long-term uh disadvantage of an
excrement vicious relationship
uh is it tends to deaden sexuality a
little bit over the years right
but
marriage is um
oh i don't know for novelists marriages
are absolutely fascinating i've used
this example over and over and over that
in a short story
people go through various
activities
and they come to the end and they gain a
point they know something they didn't
know before
and uh that's the short story in in
abstract
whereas a novel what happens is at the
end of a chapter they come to an
understanding of something they didn't
quite know before
and then the next chapter starts the
next day and they're a different person
and something else is happening
and so they might have felt at the end
of chapter one that they were doomed by
the end of chapter two they uh they
think no on the country they're really
quite a quite a man quite a woman and
they're gonna go on and do all sorts of
things then comes chapter three where
something else happens and so forth and
that's the beauty of the novel the novel
is very close to marriage marriage is
very close to the novel
and poetry is a one-night stand yeah
well that's that's the um
that's the i often said that um you know
and the poem was a one-night stand
and uh when it's written by a psychopath
it's a bummer you said that right yeah i
know you said a psychopath liz left many
poems but they're bummers
yes
um
speaking of writers who have backgrounds
as journalists and
an interest in politics
i wanted to ask you what you thought of
hunter thompson
and i also wanted to ask you uh what
didion
and if you want to get in into it also
interested in uh
okay all i got was what do i think a
hundred i didn't hear the last one
either uh i was asking about the new
journalism ask you about hunter thompson
joan didion if you would like to talk
about those two i didn't get the last
name that you mentioned
i mentioned tom wolf also oh tom wolf
right well you picked three totally
different writers
i mean you've got gotta
i love hunter thompson but the reason i
do
is because of his extraordinary gifts
uh in being able to take more drugs and
more booze and more tobacco where he
takes it more of everything than anyone
i've ever met
and he keeps his good humor and he keeps
writing lively dynamic prose he he's um
he's indescribable
uh
joan didion is an immensely skillful
rider with a great deal of address in
what she does uh she separates um
she loves to cleave into a something
she loves to separate smug
smugglers into two halves
and then bisect it again and again and
then
take from that the moral value
of what was awful in the smugness in the
first place
and then you got tom wolf and i must say
that there i once wrote a long
critical piece about him talking about
his virtues and his vices
and uh he was so furious also an updike
and john irving that he called us the
three stooges
you know well
he said we were jealous and
the comeback that came naturally to me
was that if i'm going to be jealous of a
writer it would be a tolstoy not tom
wolf
yes but wolf has one terrible flaw which
is he's the best feature writer in
america
and feature writers form very bad habits
for novels
because their characters don't their
characters have to have immense vitality
in a feature they have to stand out from
the page but there's no need to develop
them after that
and he spent the formative years writing
features very good ones the best best
around
but the fact of the matter is he doesn't
know how to develop a character and he
doesn't have a clue to what women might
be like not a clue it's not just amazing
every one of us women is a johanna one
note yeah yeah not johnny one nope
johanna one though
i fancy that
there's somebody over here
would you comment about the new fascism
in our society
did you hear that one new fashion would
you comment about the new fascism in our
society
well i'll offer you something better i
wrote a speech that i gave in san
francisco
a few nights ago at the commonwealth
club and it's going to be reprinted in
the new york review of books i think in
the next issue just went to press
yesterday and rather than try to talk
about it quickly this late in the
evening because i have some very strong
ideas about it it's there in that piece
and i recommend it to you it i worked
hard in it so i'm i'm sort of pleased
with the speaker well very often you
just wing speeches and then you're
embarrassed by them later but this one i
did work on
um
yeah i'd like to uh i'd like to ask this
theme of you said of being cheated
um
i just like to ask you about the choices
uh
you wrote about uh kennedy and then
uh the 64 convention and then the saint
george the godfather the 68-72 and i got
to feel that mailer would always write
about politicians and conventions
and then you started writing novels and
i'm just
asking that in some way cheated is not a
bad word that i missed like clinton
would have been a natural and maybe you
did write some but there's so much that
mailer could have done on clinton that
i'll never read and even george w bush
and i just wonder again the choice i
don't know if you could hear is
i miss that
and what do i do with missing it that
i'll never get to really hear mailer on
clinton
well to begin with i did write about
clinton
i had a lot of severe things to say
about clinton at the time of kosovo
uh because i felt that
you know his personal
love life and i'm the last man to start
criticizing someone else
for their love life but the fact of the
matter is uh it wasn't what he was doing
it was that uh
it didn't he should have if you're
president you do have a few obligations
to other people
and and one of them was he he couldn't
go to war in kosovo properly we had to
fly in at 15 000 feet and make sure not
one single american was killed because
clinton at that point was in such shaky
ground in his presidency that one drop
of american blood could have done them
in
so that war was a horror
the one in kosovo
but i know i've written about clinton
critically uh the worst thing clinton
ever did
was to spay his dog
i mean pretend this is vast love for his
dog
and um
you know i could just see hillary saying
to a certain point if you don't get that
dog gelding that dog is going to spew
and spray all over one of the art female
interns
so cut the dog's nuts off
and then the dog died i think they lost
the dog was a nice dog yeah
he could he didn't want to live after
that
um i don't know if we have time for
one more
yes
one more question one more can you tell
us what you're enjoying these days in
current popular entertainment and
why
something about popularity what are you
enjoying these days in current popular
entertainment and why oh
i think that was um
the only thing i really enjoyed in the
last couple years i guess was the
sopranos
i did enjoy it although i finally wore
my interest wore out
uh oh before that what i'd like very
much was um
um david lynch's work in twin peaks the
first couple of installments were
exceptional then it got it fell apart
but generally speaking in popular
entertainment i don't know i don't have
time to see movies anymore
uh because i now work in the evening
and so by the time we eat
time we finish dinner every night it's
10 30 and where i live there no movie
theaters open at past 11. so i don't see
all the good movies i finally in
desperation bought a big television set
so i could buy dvd films and put them on
the t on the tv set and maybe see a
movie or two i can't speak about movies
with any uh choices as that as a result
this is a this is why i wanted to read
something at the end of the day
yeah because you see i've what i've
learned in question periods
is by the time you answer the last
question you can hear your own voice
and so if you're going to hear your own
voice you might as well read something
that you've written
so it's 2 30 oh you have it wonderful i
haven't some things might fall out here
there we go oh i just got to get my
glasses on here we go
oh thank you
[Music]
a playwright named john ford noonan
wrote a very funny play it's called
talking things over with jacob
and he tells a story in in the play one
of the characters in the play tells a
story
and i'll just read my note it lived for
me with such intensity that i came to
decide it was true
whether or not it actually happened was
beside the point
it was just too good a story not to
believe it took place
all right so this is my version of the
story that john ford noonan told
originally
somewhere around the turn of the century
we have chekhov visiting tolstoy
he takes the train to the nearest
station
let's say it's wintertime
he rents two horses
and a sled and drives out through the
snow to yaznia polyana
toaster is pretty old by now
big strong
severe of course
and sits them right down and they talk
they drink tea and they talk
telstra says jacob you're a very good
writer
you're excellent
some of your short stories are so good i
would have been pleased to have written
them myself
but chekhov i must tell you
you are a terrible playwright
you are awful
you are even worse than shakespeare
afterwards chekhov drives back to the
railroad stations through the snow
in his journal he will write
i whipped the horses
to the moon i shouted
i am even worse than shakespeare
it's a fine story
but if it's true
why did tolstoy dislike shakespeare so
i expect the answer is that tolstoy was
always searching for subtle
but precise moral judgment
that required a detailed sense of any
sequence of events which had produced a
dramatic or tragic event
you had to know how to assess the blame
for that you needed to know exactly when
and why things happened
but they're very much in the way with
shakespeare
the greatest movie writer who ever
existed
centuries before cinema had a silver
screen
for shakespeare was not interested in
making careful connections with his
characters
shakespeare was looking to get the most
dynamic actors together under any
circumstance available no matter how
contrived
king lear can be the first example
he was looking for superb exchanges of
dialogue and fantastic moments
vitigenous possibilities for the english
language
whereas telstra looked for sobriety of
moral judgment
so he considered shakespeare a monster
who paid no attention to causality
except when it was useful to him
will's people did incredible things
fell in love or murdered
the latter with a minimum of preparation
macbeth
and then had exceptional speeches that
seared an audience's consciousness
to tolstoy this was monstrous
it must have been equal to the way some
of us look these days upon advertising
campaigns
that are stuffed with manipulation and
little else
but why tolstoy would compare chekov to
shakespeare is another question
i don't know that anyone is prepared to
answer
if there is a reason i suspect it was
for a different set of thoughts
telstra i may have felt that chekhov was
a prelude to someone yet to arrive
someone like beckett
in his plays chekhov's people were
simply not doing what they ought to be
doing
what had to irritate tolstoy immensely
was that anton's play actors sat in
their own spiritual excrement and made
sweet speeches and moaned a little
inside and groaned and never got out of
their situation
to tolstoy this was a cardinal sin
one should not live with a given when it
is vapid and vaguely immoral
that was one of tolstoy's most basic
notions
you may have to endure a dreary given as
a discipline
but you do not accept your conclusion
you don't forgive me but you do not
accept your condition as eternal
as the meaning of life
he could not permit that
could not accept how chekhov made so
much
of the
eight of the
essential ammunition
of the russian middle class
thank you you've been a fine audience
[Music]
norman mailer's latest work is the
spooky art some thoughts on writing it's
published by random house on the web at
randomhouse.com
you